[Music]
well let's
have some good news talk now thank
goodness okay
good news yeah so an arkansas
cancer clinic owner has forgiven
nearly 650 thousand dollars in unpaid
bills from about 200 patients
oh my god they don't need money so he
says that he talked to his wife and they
looked at
at what they had because they had
already closed their practice and they
were working with a billing company
or like billing collector company to try
to get
this money that was owed to the clinic
um
since he had closed in march but when he
found out that people
just genuinely were unable to pay he
he talked to his wife they looked at
what they had and they were like you
know what we can afford this like
just forgive it wow that's awesome can
you imagine that feeling of like
having this looming debt and you're like
[ __ ] and probably everything else in
life you probably have a bunch of
looming debt and then you get this
letter saying you've been forgiven
oh i think i would [ __ ] it's like
being able to fart
when you're at a fancy event oh yeah and
you're holding it and you're trying to
be all proper and [ __ ]
and then you've never farted at a fancy
event no but then the music goes loud
and everyone's clapping you go
and you're like thank god oh my god open
your butt cheeks a little bit
no see i can't do it silently yeah
girl's got a talent
you should wear a thong and then fart
and then it splits it in half dude
i feel like girls train their whole
lives to like be able to fart but like
secretly oh yeah i just did it right now
or dude if you do it during like a fast
and furious movie you can fart the
entire time because
everything's going off dude skills you
can take a [ __ ] in your lap and nobody
will know see i never
trained that's how does it go into your
lap yeah
well think of it well you don't know how
it goes around you don't know how balls
work actually
if you are really going to diarrhea
pretty hard your balls can sometimes act
as
the consistency and it all just kind of
comes up and out on the on the top of
the legs yeah
it's a whole [ __ ] while you're in a
toilet or like no no why you're sitting
on a chair yeah
so the week of christmas around 200 of
his former patients received a holiday
greeting
card that read it said i hope this note
finds you well the arkansas cancer
clinic
was proud to serve you as a patient
although various
health insurances pay most of the bills
for a majority of patients
even the deductibles and co-pays can be
burdensome oh yeah
unfortunately that is the way our health
care system currently works
arkansas's cancer clinic is closing its
practice
after over 29 years of dedicated service
to the community the clinic has decided
to forego
all balances owed to the clinic by its
patients happy holidays
that's amazing did they get any feedback
from anyone
not that i know of actually imagine
nobody said a damn
thing they're like awesome yeah good
thanks something i thought
we did a good thing what if the people
that they sent it to already dead
oh [ __ ] i was hoping i was hoping no so
now he's a professor at the university
of arkansas for medical
sciences in little rock and so he gave
up his practice and now he's teaching
he's teaching but he also has four
children all of whom are
either doctors or studying to become
doctors is this for asian or something
oh
indian indian that counts yeah that
counts
that is such a beautiful gesture man
like and it's so sad that we all go
wow because it's so [ __ ] rare now i
know the real motive why he did it
because now he can always hold that over
the head of his children
oh like you know what your [ __ ] dad
did yeah
650 grand i was like [ __ ] that [ __ ]
that's how dope i
am wouldn't that be cool if they did
that with student loans all these people
i feel so bad
yeah i want to see a university
president come out and go you know what
forgive yeah but think about all those
student loan lenders
yeah think about the lenders the
government hell yeah yeah yeah exactly
all the banks that i'm invested in yeah
don't fail banks i need more money
yeah so this doctor who said since i
started practicing i've always been
rather uncomfortable with sick patients
not only having to worry about their own
health and quality of life and their
longevity
and their families and their jobs but
also money
you add it to the absolute devastation
that the coronavirus pandemic has
wrought and you think thank god that
we're
fairly comfortable and that this is
something we could at least do to help
the community
damn that's awesome it's a crazy weird
business like the place that
i go to get rapid tests um
they pretty much converted the whole
urgent care place to just do rapid tests
it makes the most money
yeah and i'm like okay 150 bucks per
person
and it looks like they can do like 10
people an hour and they don't take
insurance yeah so it's all cash yeah so
it's like 1500
an hour times i don't know how long
they're open at least 10 now it's like
15 g's a day like 7 a.m to 7 p.m yeah so
maybe 12 for more than 15 gs a day and
i'm like
are they doing this to serve the
community or are they doing it to make
hell of money you know it's just i don't
know because
you could do the government tests right
now for free and the home kids you just
everything's free it's just if you want
it done right now you just
yeah it's crazy there's this one
university i recently read about i
forgot what it was but
or like which which university but they
have 11 vending machines
for students to just go up and get their
the covet test
for free or kit yeah for free damn
see that's when it comes to like public
health and things like that
um and necessities i feel really weird
about
charging as a society like as a as a
community
charging for someone to to get better
the sick like if we have the resources
to do it
that feels like a basic human right now
for extra [ __ ] right if you want like
cosmetic surgery or if you want things
that like for beauty reasons or whatever
that makes sense to charge for that or
like it's
it's like getting a personal trainer for
fitness or whatever right but then when
it comes to like survival
and basic needs i don't know man that's
so weird this is the great debate around
our health care system
well why does that to be a debate well
it has to be a
why does it have to like what you're
saying it's like it should just be uh
something nice yeah not everyone sees it
like that it's privatized right now so
they like your doctors are paying an arm
and a leg to go through all their
medical school to get training now they
have student loan debt they got to pay
that back they have to make money
somehow
it's privatized or we go the government
takes over
all of the health care um but then
everyone gets the same exact
like uh resources god forbid and
sometimes
they can i don't know they can squeeze
like how public schooling is like
not everyone gets the same i mean levels
of education
like could easily go the other way where
like uh now all the doctors have the
same attitude that dmv workers have
so it's like i don't know it's just so
it's just on the same token i agree with
joe i feel like
you know like the basic human health
should be covered and
something that we don't all have to
worry about but then it's the system and
structuring and creating the operational
part of that
that's extremely very it's extremely
difficult because then i can also see an
our doctor coming out like
i studied my ass off i was the best
student in my high school college
medical school
in my practice i can see a thousand
patients a day
and be that much of a benefit to society
why am i getting paid the most as that
shitty doctor across
or being paid the same as actually a
doctor across the street you know so
then it becomes a debate oh it should be
privatizing they should be in control
yeah because i'm just making an
emotional point right like i
feel that it should be a certain way but
then when we get into the logistics of
it it becomes
so [ __ ] complicated but to me okay
look it's called medicare for all
i think it makes sense right like look
at
you look at congress you look at our
senators everybody
they all have like the [ __ ] best
healthcare in the world
they all have like their own private
ones right but but they have like the
[ __ ]
like highest echelon of that why can't
we just give that to everybody
and yes maybe it is going to be very
expensive okay but they don't seem to
have a problem paying for all a lot of
things that are very expensive
so why not do something for us for once
and that's why i'm i'm indian and it's
good for
in my opinion i think it's good for the
economy to have
a long living consumer base
but what's not beneficial to them
and the lobbyists and everyone that's
benefiting immediately is the
pharmaceutical companies
they get paid by people being sick and
if you have
and treatment good health staying sick
human beings in your country
that are consuming medicine and all that
stuff you don't have that much of a
medical industry
yeah so because of that reason when
money gets involved and all that
corruption is involved and a lot of
people are getting paid
they don't want to let go of that cash
cow so
i think that's the issue but then my
whole point is like
i don't know i think long-term wise to
build a good
strong long-term nation you do need
healthy citizens
yeah did you see i think it was
indonesia that they're going to be
giving the vaccine the copa vaccine to
working adults before they give it to
the elderly hmm
i mean they're because they're like more
like in the public and necessary
i just think that during a pandemic you
you could
you could have done this so easily
you're talking about the debate right
like
yeah we have to do a debate well
everyone's scared shitless about health
care especially during a pandemic
send the bill into congress every
[ __ ] week i want to know the names of
the people who say no to medicare for
all
you give me those names every week that
you guys send the bill in who says no
and just keep [ __ ] doing it
because these [ __ ] will have to do
something eventually yep
well here's the thing right is like
they're more likely
so the stimulus bills and the money that
they're printing
for so people could pay their bills and
stuff right well the recent one came out
and you know they did the math and it's
only like 600 bucks per person i think
trump made it
a thousand or two now yourself right but
i don't know if that got passed well no
this the republicans stopped it in the
senate
and then now joe biden says he's gonna
do it so right so
so the thing is even at 2000 right it's
not a lot of it's still going to things
that are like why
like if you see where it's going to
you're like how the [ __ ] did this
company get it
or like this foundation or like they we
found out that we're giving it to
foreign nations i think like
was it israel or like they different
countries are getting which ones aren't
getting it i mean that's so so i'm like
okay so we're in a pandemic and health
is related
and i don't hear any news maybe there is
money going to healthcare or whatever
but i don't hear anything of it that's
why i want receipts because it's like
okay everybody should it we should all
you're right we should all get universal
healthcare and i think everyone kind of
agrees on that because it's like
why should polls really well by the way
both parties everyone should everyone
should get that right but then it's like
how much do you i think the debate is
like how much do you trust the
government to actually give us
proper health care because we did it
with the schools and the dmv and it's
all [ __ ] up
so like where's that money going we
don't know because
we don't get receipts it could be going
anywhere we don't know i'm glad you
asked that because medicare actually
according to polling of people who use
it is one of the highest rated things
like in the country so so they like they
like they like using medicare so that's
why
i liked using medi-cal when i had it so
that's why the medicare for all plan
i think is the sickest of anything i've
heard proposed when it comes to
universal health care
i think we should have a system of two
right so like basic
like doctor visits all the checkups all
the things that we need
like if we get a flu or cold or all
those things doctor visits
that should be covered anything on top
of that specialized
privatized things is okay if you want
expedite it if you want
you just put the extra like the rapid
test i feel like that's
what drives a good incentive for
our you know top brightest doctors to be
in america to like
you know work on these special brain
diseases that only 100 people have or
whatever and that's why everyone comes
here
to get those type of specialized treated
things
and so like we do have great health care
if you can't afford it
but these outrageous prices like you
break your leg and then you have to go
to the hospital and then the ambulance
charges you 10 grand for the ride that's
some [ __ ] up [ __ ]
how about just people being terrified to
use our healthcare system because they
know they're going to get a huge
[ __ ] bill so how many like are are
you know the birth um quality of of like
the amount of infants that die the rate
of the mortality rate for babies has
gone up
because mothers right because of that
because people are like well i'm not
going to go do all the prenatal care and
all this stuff like because it costs too
much costs too much so then they're by
the time that they're in
the hospital actually delivering or not
in hospital delivering
they're in a really precarious situation
so
there are huge costs that already exist
that don't get tallied
when we talk about healthcare at all
it's really sad so sad
but you know good thing we have
politicians who are really going to ram
this thing
[Applause]
[Music]
you